I'm so glad you're with me today we have
so much to talk about I want to start
with this if you are angry that Hillary
Clinton won the popular vote by even
more than I told you last week but
Donald Trump is going to be our next
president it almost sounds like I'm
telling a joke but no Donald Trump is
going to be our next president then you
can actually do something about it and
this is a bigger and bigger discussion
among progressives and among some
Republicans where we know that in nearly
10 percent of elections because of this
thing called the electoral college the
candidate with more votes doesn't become
president so we know about 2016 with
Hillary Clinton that's not even a week
old most of us remember 2000 with Al
Gore
there was also as Pat told us last week
1824 1876 and 1888 the math tells us
that in eight point six percent of
elections for president in the United
States the candidate who receives more
votes does not win now even Trump agrees
with the fact that this doesn't really
seem good this may be something that now
he would change his mind on although
yesterday in his 60 minutes interview he
still did say no he stands by his
comments I'll remind you what Donald
Trump previously said about the
electoral college where he says more
votes equals a loss revolution let's
fight like hell and stop this great and
disgusting injustice the world is
laughing at us we can't let this happen
we should march on Washington and stop
this travesty the phony Electoral
College made a laughingstock out of our
nation the loser won of course Donald
Trump writing Oh any I'm sure he meant
wo n as far as one so even Trump agrees
with us on this and I already discussed
last week with you why this system is
particularly terrible now given that
many of the reasons for the original
creation of the electoral college are no
longer relevant if you believe in
one-person one-vote the Electoral
College goes against that and Pat
explained last week the disproportionate
power that voters in swing states have
but it's even more than that
even the number of electoral votes
doesn't directly relate to the number of
voters in a state and if you look based
on population and electoral votes for
example base
in 2012 results and we can put this
graph up for people to see a Texas voter
has a quarter of the electoral power as
a Wyoming voter and this is based on the
number of people per electoral vote in
Texas there are three quarters of a
million voters for one electoral vote
and as you can see here as you go to the
right of this graph in North Dakota in
Alaska in Vermont there are fewer voters
per electoral vote meaning that voters
have a different amount of electoral
power now this is totally aside from the
reality that if you vote for the loser
in your state your vote essentially has
no meaning and value and this is where
we even get the concepts of third party
protest votes and no votes and all of
these other things it this is this is
something that is a really big deal to a
lot of people and not just because it
led to Hillary Clinton losing now one
path to changing the system is a
constitutional amendment I say basically
forget about that pad I mean it's almost
pointless to discuss a constitutional
amendment to change our voting system
right a constitutional amendment hasn't
happened since the 1970s it's been a
whole generation and on a topic like
this where it's really not partisan
either way it's not gonna happen
it's partisan right now and it's sort of
feeling that way but over time both
Republicans and Democrats have said you
know this is that really the best system
now a better path forward is something
called the national popular vote
interstate compact I mentioned this last
week the idea is a state can decide that
no matter how our state votes we will
cast our electoral ballots for the
winner of the popular vote and remember
Donald Trump said it best himself as I
previously told you I'll put this tweet
up on the screen for you the Electoral
College is a disaster for democracy so
how would this work
step one states sign this interstate
popular vote compact for now nothing
changes once you have enough states
agreeing to the National interstate
ellaktor a popular vote compact that in
total they add up to 270 electoral votes
enough to win the election they say from
now on
we'll give our electoral votes to
whoever wins the popular vote this is
very popular 70% support for a
nationwide vote for president and so far
there are 10 states plus the District of
Columbia that are in favor of this this
is about a hundred and sixty five
combined electoral votes just need a
hundred and five more there's active
legislation in Arizona in Michigan and
Pennsylvania in Missouri that would add
fifty seven electoral votes which would
get us to 222 this Pat is actually the
best path forward for a national popular
vote yeah I think it sounds great my
concern is that some states will take on
the method of Nebraska and Maine which
is to split votes by congressional
district yeah which sounds like it would
be more representative but the fact is
that these districts have been so badly
gerrymandered right now it would really
just give the Republicans a large boost
in theory the idea of just proportional
electoral vote allocation in every
single state sounds not bad but because
of what we've seen with these dress
districts and gerrymandering it's really
a disaster if you're a single red voice
in a blue sea if you are a blue voice in
a red sea call it what you want you
would end up feeling much less
disenfranchised with a national popular
vote it should be done away with it is
very undemocratic and we're going to be
including this we've got some big
announcements to make on the show and
this discussion is going to be a really
really big part of that